good morning believe nation its Evan my
one word is believe and I believe that
you have something special that when you
unleash it it will be able to change the
world so to help you on your journey
today's message is work hard over to you
James Hetfield most things in life that
are worthwhile you got to work at you
got to work at you get out what you put
in as simple as that that's a kind of a
universal law so yeah it's not pick up
the guitar and go haha which I've done
you know home front of the mirror Lots
you know hey I'm really good and you got
to have that attitude too but it does
take work it does take you know some
dedication you know but if you love
doing it it's not as hard as is it is it
could be if you're you know you're doing
something that's not it you're not as
interested in so on this channel we've
covered more successful people maybe
than any other channel on YouTube I'd
put it up against a lot of other
internet properties just in general
we've covered entrepreneurs and athletes
and musicians and innovators and
politicians and people who have had
success from all walks of life and one
of the most consistent themes that come
up is you need to work hard everybody
works hard there's nobody who is really
crushing it who's spending ten hours a
week working on their thing and you have
to love what you're doing because that's
the only way you're going to keep doing
it the only way you're gonna deal with
all of the crap of learning your craft
and all the rejection and all the
feelings and all the things that don't
work out at the beginning the only thing
that gets you through is you actually
love the process you love the work so it
doesn't feel like work it's it's one of
the most repeated piece of advice that
come over and over and over and over
again on this channel and so if you want
to become world-class at something you
want to be the Michael Jordan of your
industry then you have to put in the
work to get really really really really
good and yes you're working smart but
you have to work hard as well and so a
quick story with Alex from
Donavan salsa who I hired to help me run
the business and he's also an instructor
here I recently made a video where we
were talking about him wanting to be the
best instructor in Canada at salsa and
who's trying to figure out his schedule
and he wanted to go down to one or two
days a week and I told them that if you
want to be the best once or twice a week
is not enough in your world could get
yield just each of all six and just
teaching Monday's sign up you think it's
not enough for you to get good I think
you'll lose it
really yeah if you wanted to just be a
manager and just be a coach
then it's a different story but if you
want to be the best instructor doing one
night a week it's not gonna be enough
mm-hmm yeah I didn't think about that I
don't want to be mediocre and then if I
bring that to my own business if I want
to have more success on YouTube I need
to put in more reps like I'm doing three
videos a day we've done over 5,000
videos on this channel right like you
better get better at something if you're
doing at 5,000 times over and over and
over and over and over again when I
started working with my agency I was
considered the worst and I became the
best in a couple months not because I
had talent or skill was because I was
doing three videos a day when everybody
else is having a hard time trying to do
one video a week right you're just
you're just gonna get better faster
because you're putting in the work and
so whatever it is that you want to get
great at and and obviously some
restrictions maybe have a full time job
you know maybe you can't dedicate 100%
of time to it yet it's understandable
but you need to work every day on your
craft I need to get better and better
and better and better and better
consistently Michael Jordan became
Michael Jordan because of all the
practice that he did did he have natural
talent yes but he worked and he worked
and he worked and if you just write
people off and you look at anybody who's
at the top of their field and you say
well they're there because they're just
they were naturally gifted if that's the
reasoning for why they're successful and
why you aren't more successful you're
gonna lose don't disrespect
the amount of effort and hard work that
they are putting in don't disrespect the
amount of hard work Michael Jordan put
into becoming Michael Jordan because if
you just chalk it up to natural talent
you're gonna lose
you're gonna lose it whatever it is that
you're doing hard work almost always
beats natural talent in almost any field
and that sucks because it's a lot of
hard work but it's also great in that
anybody can win like if you badly want
to win at what you're doing as an
entrepreneur as an actor as a singer as
a guitarist whatever it is if you badly
want to win you can you just have to pay
the price of hard work so the question
today today is I'm curious are you
working hard enough on the thing that
you say you want to be great at are you
really putting in enough work to become
the best I would love to hear from you
leave your thoughts down in the comments
below I also want to give a quick shout
out to Boaz Boaz thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book your one
word I appreciate the support and I hope
you'll enjoy the reading so thank you
guys again for watching I believe in you
I hope we continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love and I'll see you guys again
tomorrow morning for another shot of
vinspresso
[Music]
being in a band you have to constantly
reinvent yourself you have to constantly
be reminded you know how there's someone
better than you every other weekend and
you have the constant your constant
reminded how you would have nothing
without your fans you know so you have
to take into account what they're
thinking and yeah what they're
interested in yeah and all those things
matter it doesn't but it doesn't matter
what art you do it does a matter if it's
in making an album or a movie or book or
whatever you have to think of thinking
about all those types of things is poor
the hard work involved I mean if you if
you want to have like a casual life and
you don't want to be in a pan I mean you
never sleep it's really really hard work
you know and you're exhausted all the
time and you're almost always sick and
you're fighting with your business
partners all day long and it's a it's
just how it is but I have a very very
strong work ethic because I had nothing
when I was a kid nothing I'd been
working on my first job when I was 13 I
had two jobs when I was 16 you know and
um but I would I think it's a lot of
it's probably because I'm
extraordinarily fearful about having to
do what someone tells me to do so I'd
rather be doing everything because at
least no one's telling me to do that you
literally are for many of us in this
room and watching movie wise you are the
soundtrack of our lives so much of your
stuff is obviously well known to your
point some stuff maybe not as well known
but how do you know is there something
inside of you how do you know when you
get it right
what's that this do you know when you
get it right very very rarely you hope
that you've gotten 90% of it or you as
close to as you can but at least with me
and I think with most writers of any
kind you do really don't say Eureka this
is it yeah it's working this come back
the next week and reshape it and do it
like a scope you know keep honing away
at it I'm not so brilliant that I can
sit down and write a melody or a theme
or a whole scene or a whole work as
Mozart might have done we're told you
know dashing it off like a letter and
the grammar is perfect yeah
it's varying music at least what I
always very very hard-working for
Orchestra particularly you know it's
it's so it's it's a labor-intensive
thing I have to be in a room alone or
all the time
where's that so that's so
it's a life that is and hardworking it's
lonely work it's hard work it's lonely
work it's labor-intensive I still use a
pencil and paper I don't have a computer
and you always go oh I've been so busy
fortunately yeah you know that I haven't
been able to go back and retool because
I was studying music no or no computer
yeah we didn't have it secret to success
as a couple of elements that are
important in success first of all is
your own level of expectation you also
have to learn to be happy with what you
achieve sometimes it's impossible in
life to always achieve exactly what you
have in the back of your head so you
need to learn also to be happy with what
you achieved even if it's only half of
what you had in mind at first I like a
quote of John Lennon life's what's
happened life's what's happening to you
when you're busy making other plans and
that is what I keep telling my wife as
well and and all a lot of people around
me you always expect something and then
something along the way comes and then
you have to alter your path again and if
you can learn to live with that if you
can be practical like that then success
is more easy maybe it's good to have a
plan but it's also good done if you're
working really hard and you're walking
up against a door and you can't go
through that door then you know you just
find a back door is find your way around
it and that's just the way that life is
sometimes you cannot get exactly what
you want or what you had in the back of
your mind yes it's very important that
you have to have a good work ethic
nobody gets anywhere without hard work
and you'll have good and bad days even
myself as a producer I run into
disappointments almost on a daily basis
because I try to work with artists that
on the last moment pull back their song
or you know you don't see that you don't
read that in the news but it's a fact of
the matter and I think all artists have
to deal with stuff like that you don't
get the set times you want you don't get
the billing you want you don't get the
hotel room that you request it it's
something you have to deal with and it
you know defines your character how easy
you are to do with stuff like that you
know life is a rollercoaster ride for
everybody it has its ups and it's downs
but if everything goes well you'll have
more ups and downs and you'll remember
the ups more than you'll remember the
downs but it's a fact of the matter that
everybody no matter if
you're a big artist and successful
artist or a successful businessmen
everybody works hard to get somewhere